I was injured when I was 15 years old
when I dived into a swimming pool hit my
head at the bottom of the pool and broke
my neck swimming something that broke me
and that reconstituted me once again I
like telling people that is the place
where I found my damnation and my
salvation I arrived here in the fall of
2015 for a PhD degree in history
anthropology and science and technology
studies so that's a bit of a mouthful so
why don't you give me a sense of you
know if there's a particular moment in
that broader Cold War history that
you're actually kind of leaning towards
and what I study is the history of
modern medicine and the ongoing crisis
of antibiotic resistance we live in a
time where in the span of a hundred
years we've gone from the triumphs of
antibiotics to actually confronting a
future where they don't work
I was born 28 years ago in India my
father was a poultry farmer I went to
boarding school I did my undergraduate
and my master's degrees in Delhi and I
found myself by some luck and a lot of
hard work here
[Music]
I live in a graduate residence hall
called the warehouse I'm in fact one of
the Resident Assistants there I want to
be a teacher ultimately I like teaching
I like research I like a life of the
mind
in a context where the body is not at
its optimum I think the mind sort of
supplements and I think the best place
for mental stimulation is possibly where
we are right now
[Music]